good morning believe nation today's
message is understand your point of
impact over to you Michael Dell think
about the the the point of impact if
you're running a business with a hundred
people the point of impact for the
leader is very different than if it's a
thousand people or 10,000 100,000 and so
that's the frame of reference that I've
always used is to say okay if I'm
leaving this organization what are the
things that actually I can do to cause
it to be successful if it's a thousand
people it's very very different than it
is for me today so today I have a lot
more focus on strategy because that's
the point of impact
110 thousand person company on a hundred
person company you know you're sort of
doing any job in the organization you're
doing every job in the organization you
know potentially and that might be okay
at that point this is really important
message for entrepreneurs and I think
more important for entrepreneurs than
for CEOs because you are doing in some
cases all the work for your business and
if you have a team you're still doing a
significant amount and where you spend
your time is critical because if you're
spending on the wrong things and the
wrong projects your business isn't gonna
grow I find a lot of entrepreneurs are
very reactionary you're putting out
fires all the time and often you could
go home and feeling like you didn't get
anything really valuable done today one
of the things that I found super helpful
when I was starting my business was when
I was walking to work it was about 15
minute walk on that walk I would always
think to myself where can I add the most
value today what can I do today that's
really going to help my business grow
whether it's making phone calls whether
it's creating content whether it's
working with my team whatever it was
what can I do today that will have a
significant impact on my business that's
what I thought every day on my walk to
the company and that would be the first
thing that I did before I got distracted
before emails came in before fire
started coming up I would
focus on that so I would know every day
that I would get stuff done and be able
to grow my business by finding again a
lot of entrepreneurs you're so busy just
reacting to things you're so busy doing
so many things in a scattered way that
you don't and you don't get anything
great done on the one or two things that
will really help drive your business
forward so understand your point of
impact and make it a deal II happen
think to yourself even if the walk to
your office is from your bedroom to the
next room or bedroom to the garage where
you're setting up shop wherever that
walk is think about it as what is the
biggest value that I could bring to my
company today to help me grow so my
question today for you today is what's
the biggest area of impact that you can
have on your business today I'm really
curious to find out leave it in the
comments below thank you so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe and I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot of vinspresso